[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh i could use the brick
i am exhausted oh my goodness hello and
uh we're so happy to [ __ ] be here
that's right starting up the show with a
big old super chat thank you nice uh
thank you alien mafia i hope i'm on your
good side wink welcome back to the break
room uh we're so happy to have you here
all your breakers your roomies your
super trash this is our daily live show
live from the new rock stars break room
here at our secret new rockstars
headquarters that you'll never find stop
trying to find it uh
we're coming live from our very real
very own break room where we sometimes
eat snacks but mostly just do this daily
live show now yeah uh we've got a big
big news filled fun-filled show for you
today we're going to be talking about
doctor strange 2 news uh the boys
preparing to traumatize us all over
again this week uh and you know we're
going to be talking about the final
episode of kenobi
this will be a very spoilery episode so
if you didn't watch it save this video
for a little bit later and we'll get to
it you can come back to it then but for
all of you here live right now let's
talk about kenobi uh and it's not just
me brandon talking about canada i'm
joined with some lovely people here
today across the table back welcome back
to the break room it's coy jandro it's
so good to be here we're glad to have
you back in this kenobi thing it's like
i've been gearing up to have a place to
talk about it already wearing my best
boba fett shirt yeah yeah
we barely slept uh so much to watch last
night jessica has been watching content
since yesterday afternoon yeah i've
hopped up on that spice so i'm like wow
that's all i can do is
today introduce you it's okay i'm so
i'm talking to you here
tired you guys so if i get really
less talkative it's because i've been
awake since midnight if jessica starts
to fall asleep let's put some claps in
the chat like
wake up uh and that's everyone at the
table today i believe just kidding tom
rebecca's here hey
guys so great to be here again woke up
with a smile on my face just so grateful
for all the wonderful viewers that we
have every single one of you means
something to me and i know in the past
i've called you all garbage and
worthless and soulless and you have no
lives and no meaning and that was the
old me the new me thinks you're all
shiny pieces of treasure okay and i put
you in my treasure chest and i hide you
under my bed for a thousand years what a
sweet boy yeah such a loving threat but
yeah yeah
still the the threat was still there and
i don't know if i trust him ever since
the chicken bone scene when girl
interrupted i don't trust anything
underneath i
love that scene i don't trust anything
under the bed that's that's for all you
20 year olds and whatever did she say i
know who did it no that's a difference
that's a different one yeah a different
movie and she says i'll never test i'll
never tell uh but she's spelling out the
numbers with her fingers spoiler all
right
1997.
folks we already broke the swear jar you
know we're not allowed to swear on this
show uh but if we raise a hundred
dollars in super chats we can break the
swear jar and do some swearing
uh alien mafia made sure that we already
did that the the kostra nostru ufo
i stretched all right that was a video
coaster
ghoster
i'm sure it's in the wu-tang meme
uh well tommy they voted in the chat i
stole your swear but if you want to
squeak out a little swearing you know
i'm gonna see my niece on friday i'm
gonna say her favorite swear word ding
dong dixon oh ding dong dixon yeah
you're not supposed to say that on the
internet uh since we already booked a
hundred dollars i think if we break 200
dollars we we can swear again but i
think we should put a little star wars
spin on yeah in honor of the day maybe
throw a swear into your favorite star
wars quote yes
that's a great that's a good one
yeah nerf hurt
what is it that uh greedo likes to say
or uh uh they say it on mandalorian all
the time
yeah but you can throw in a little uh
there was one episode of mandalorian in
season two where he rattles off like 50
of them
and i remember being like i got to take
note of that and then i didn't just use
this celebration
walk around cursing it
he goes off so yeah let's get to that
200 and do some star wars level square
star wars level swearing because we are
talking obi-wan kenobi today uh so send
in your thoughts about the finale send
in some theories you might have about
where we go from here send in your
questions uh i mean we know where we go
from here for six other movies yeah uh
seven other decent amount of tv shows
yeah tv shows but you know what could
happen in the next week that we that
they haven't covered you never no no if
you got lingering questions put those in
the chat we're we're going off today on
obi-wan kenobi uh it's a force fest baby
and we're having we're having a good
time but first
before you get your dessert you gotta
eat your vitamins that means you get
some headlines
that's right at my house we didn't have
dinner we just had vitamins yeah
it went well he's from the future
we only eat vitamins athletic greens
athletic greens angel food cake
and we want to thank athletic greens
hey first headline dr stranger in the
multiverse of madness is now streaming
on disney plus and marvel
and the marvel studios assembled episode
on the making of that film will will be
released on july 1st if you watched it
last night with amongst everything else
i don't know how you fit it into your
schedule yes that was really cool of
them to just be like oh here's the movie
you've been waiting to see again yeah
well you pay for disney plus but you
know what i mean also here's two new
episodes of the show you've been
watching and also umbrella academy came
out has there ever been a week quite
like that i know we look at like weeks
of content but a finale of obi-wan the
third episode of miss marvel which is
like one of the newer great characters
of the last decade in marvel a hero-gasm
episode coming up and an actual drop of
a multi-million dollar show all within
the nerd space we oh we can get those
before the problem is it was all in one
day yeah plus heroes yeah it's like
here's three shows plus your orgasm
tomorrow and i'm like and then 10 hours
of umbrella again yeah and i watched it
all and i am tired
and i showed up on this show and they
said we're not going to talk an ounce
about it
we were sleeping last night
we were staying that's right uh and i
just want to point out to my aunt uh you
can now watch that mr strange movie on
disney plus uh he's a doctor he went to
sleep
i know but please stop asking me when mr
strange is going to be available on
disney plus it's now the answer is now
mr strange is my father yes that's the
black phone available friday
oh my goodness hey here's another
headline uh christian bale gave an
interview at games two games radar maybe
at games radar uh in which he discussed
his influence keep asking me questions
don't block his light whatever you do uh
so he gave an interview to gamesradar
and he was discussing his influences on
creating the character of gore the god
butcher uh hopefully the comics fit in
there somewhere but for the physical
living breathing representation of it he
credits taiko otisi's vision for most of
the character smart let the director
tell you what to do uh but also said he
drew some information inspiration from
nosferatu yes you might know him as the
original dracula well not the original
the original film dragon family i know
dracula is great
watch william defoe in shadow of the
vampires
he was nominated for an oscar didn't win
that year but there were some heavy
hitters right here that's okay well
willem's never won an oscar can i derail
this entire show let's go to willem's
filmography let's see yeah let's put it
down let's talk about boondock saints
his uh monologue for saturday night live
was like oh you are that nuts like you
are that crazy he's just got this great
crazy uncle here i love that he does
he's great from milwaukee
who knew from johnny
so christian bell he credits nosferatu
maybe william dafoe's performance who
knows uh he credits kate bush
the singer running up that hill he's
he's just making up you might have been
looking around the room
headlines wall um a light switch he was
looking at like the bushes outside he's
like kate
but then he also he also credited the
afix twins music video come today i
don't like the idea of christian bale
listening to the apex
so i heard that kate bush was actually
supposed to be in not the not the person
but there was a kate bush song they
actually got the rights to for
yeah so
they ran out of run time so apparently
there's a dance sequence and he talked
about dancing to kate bush so i think
this might be legit but what i love is
that we were this close to kate bush
being in theaters and at home on netflix
wow after an entire generation didn't
know who she was we almost had double
capabilities i could see them also
taking it out because they're like oh
god tick tock time
trending at all times
she's making so much money right because
she wrote produced and like that's all
her go off right make that show get that
money from the charger
in the top 10 in the us
like what uh 35 40 years did she chart
in the eighties or first time in the
eighties i don't think her song charted
in the top ten okay running of the
hilton i did i don't think it made the
top 10 in the u.s don't quote me on that
that's insane i think that's what i read
on reddit but we're going to cover all
the billboard charts uh in our next
segment talking charts william defoe
singles in the 80s
i just like to picture christian bale
sitting in his like limo or whatever
he's one of those or he's on an airplane
watching like youtube music videos like
one of those weirdos yeah there's a
bunch of music yeah daddy
oh no he definitely rihanna the rude
i like the idea of like everyone having
a song that inspires their character and
you find out years later like what
daniel day-lewis apparently wouldn't
wear a jacket for gangs in new york
because it wasn't period of pro and his
method but he'd listen eminem
yeah so he literally got pneumonia but
marshall mathers had
to hire a person to sing it to him yeah
he was tired of it at that point mp3
player
of him in full get up on set just like
from new york and just being like you
got an eminem and it's like the old
school button and it's like during the
time of funny eminem so it's like are
you doing accents
that's why that's why the butcher is so
insane untethered in that movie yeah
whoopsie daisy like he's like just
listening to
my bed
[Laughter]
uh hey next headline the long
anticipated herogasm episode i don't
know how we'll anticipated we feel more
i toss them like scared yeah
the the hirogasm episode of the boys is
set to drop tomorrow and amazon is
bracing viewers for the worst or best
with a never before seen
not suitable for any audience content
warning we have a uh still of it here
we'll pop up on the screen they had they
put out a little teaser video and this
is it says like this episode depicts a
massive soup orgy airborne penetration
dildo based maiming which you've already
had on the show extra strength lube
icicle phallus and cursing it's not
suitable for any audience is the icicle
phallus the guy i'm wondering we're
gonna watch his flashback yeah where it
gets broken up i think his name is
stewart maybe yeah it's like it's the
guy that's he works on the piano yeah he
works he's the black guy that works on
the pr team who fights with the train in
the recent episode says you don't have a
dick yeah and his face drops and we're
about to find out how and why it came
out in the first season he had had yeah
he was like a rehab for i forget her
name like ice princess or something like
that and she throws it off so we're
going to see the live so yeah i mean i'm
really terrified about it uh uh jessica
hosts the boys underground here on the
channel so she has to watch it i'm very
excited my only problem with this is
this is me and my mom's like show like
we love this show
after the first episode my mom called me
shows i thought it was a butthole and i
zoomed in zoomed out
that was the big debate this year like
was it a butthole was it a peanut well
we know what it was my mom's finally
getting turned off from it she's like
it's getting too far she's like it
wasn't this crazy last season
she was engaged to this point yeah i
love that she was like you know that was
my threshold yeah my wife wasn't on the
show and that first 15 minutes of season
three she was like i'm done
the courtroom scene where people's heads
were popping like popcorn curls that was
good that was all right
my mom loves those my mom loves violence
so that's fine it's just when you put
over there's layers
and this was like this was an episode i
believe this is a there's a comic
herogasm is incredible yeah so it's it's
a like a mini arc within the story
that's a flashback and it's actually a
separate artist derek robertson's the
main boys artist he did the covers but a
different artist inside and it somehow
was more grotesque because it felt like
you were in an elseworld-ish like you
were suddenly removed and it was more
traumatic i came out like oh eight
because the boys started no six it was a
while ago so the fact that we're getting
this now like i've been waiting weirdly
like 15 years for hero chasms like i
never thought i'd see and seth rogen
promised from the jump would get there
so the fact we're getting a whole
episode of this for issue mini the last
episode with him was enough for me i i
freaked out as soon as i saw him with
that starlight lotion
i like a man who pampers himself so i
was fine with it actually treat yourself
right oh that pole
we ran a poll do you think hirogasm will
be worse than the opening scene of
season three 78 said worse
yeah wow i don't i don't i don't think i
don't want to imagine that
uh some other poster ran are you excited
for bale's take on gore or would you
rather see a more comic book accurate
gore 88 want to see that bail see what
he's bringing to it i like it i like
that he has a nose it's great i love
that he has been noticing and are you
re-watching multiverse of madness now
that's back or it's on disney plus for
the first time 82 percent yes yeah we're
all going to watch it you got it what is
no we need more head tentacles
oh
i can't read so i thought that was to
your question i was like what was their
head tentacles and most impressive
not enough yeah um and thank you aj stan
for your uh super chat just jumping in
to say hello about to watch miss marvel
episode three much luck from michigan to
my fellow roomies
where are you are you right
here america's favorite oh the mint the
mint
the pinky
uh we're gonna talk miss marvel
uh episode three tomorrow we're saving
it for tomorrow we're gonna we gotta get
into kenobi okay so let's let's let's
get into it yeah keep dropping those
questions in the chat keep dropping what
you thought about the show your theories
where we are going forward questions
about kenobi questions about arcane yeah
um oh you said yeah no we're not talking
about arcane
we're not talking about arcane nerds
shut it down
so kenobi if you don't know wrapped up
it's uh run last night with an explosive
episode that saw obi-wan invader once
again
touching swords uh and this time it was
on a random desolate moon so the
description on the tv show was a
desolate moon on wikileaks i named the
moon beth told four
and i i think it's getting some traction
on the internet so a lot of people are
thinking that that might be that i
assumed it was one of jabim's moons but
i guess they had been flying for a
little while yeah it couldn't have been
i don't know it always seems like
because they didn't have a hyperdrive
and planets are really far apart so how
far could you really get it and how far
are moving which you could also say some
solar systems of planets are a lot
closer i don't know also like pluto what
we've lived through whether or not it
was never played
pluto get over it frankly
so let's you can plan on me bringing
pluto back into the solar system oh god
i hate this already
so so what do you guys think how do you
think this show ended for you are you
happy with how it ended uh i thought
like you know this was the battle
between obi-wan and vader we were
waiting for and when they teased it
early on and we knew obi-wan wasn't
really trying or couldn't muster up the
force yeah and vader knew it too that's
why he was like i don't want to do this
i'll be i'll be honest be honest i'll be
honest go out i wanted a little bit more
for the finale when i say more i wanted
that fight much more aggressive
um the only thing i think i was say
satiated like with was riva um and that
was like a little bit when she was
fighting them the two i was like girl
you know you like
the first time you got stabbed like why
are you beating up these two older
people
settle down please what are you gonna do
once you get the boy and then exactly
that and then um i wanted i didn't want
i didn't like that everything we were
waiting for showed up in the last five
minutes of the movie
i wanted it like yeah i wanted to
explore more but i guess we're leaving
open it ended for a second season do we
kind of feel like though that is kind of
a
thing disney plus series have been in
the brief time we've had these disney
plus kind of like giant movie franchise
spin-off series they do tend to kind of
jam a lot into the last five minutes of
their final episodes of the shows like
it's like here's a lot of answers all in
one fell swoop i for one personally felt
incredibly vindicated that so many of my
great predictions
predictions come up uh you know it was
one big victory lap i think the real
winners from last night are me
uh the little girl who plays young riva
for getting a no-line guest star credit
on uh on a star wars show for just
sitting there with her hands over her
knees i mean that's an actor's dream you
show up they don't even like the thing
it's dark they barely light it must have
been minimal setup time minimal time in
the makeup chair she's out of there
the rest of her life yep she is set
she's doing a celebration 20 30 seconds
right
oh my gosh she's gonna she's gonna know
how the rest of them feel and she's
gonna be so tired by like by like age 14
she's like i can't sign it
50 year old man every time i see
michelle nichols i'm constantly like
girl i'm so sorry she truly hates it now
and we're like get your ass off jake
lloyd just got out like jake lord just
like yeah
[Music]
i love that it felt real because like
the whole show the problem star wars is
it feels like everyone's got the force
or is this guy longer like it feels like
everyone's related and it's like a
galaxy far far away that's one planet
like i just i get sick of that it was
really nice to see like what a force
wielder would do to just peasants like
they just got handled and i love joel
edwards
so she's not actually she's not at full
tilt yeah yeah i thought this was kind
of cartoony i thought edgerton really
kind of honed in on his impression of
the of the older guy who played uncle
owen in the new hope i was like man he's
really he seems a lot like him look at
some sir alec moments from when he put
on the final bathroom
moment felt nice how did we feel about
vader then like i mean
he
literally said the exact thing and when
it happened i was like wow tommy that
was great
we were talking about the voice going
yeah when i was switching yeah in and
out of his real voice here's what i'll
say
obi-wan should be brought up on charges
for allowing vader to live okay
basically well not even i won't even say
again because he assumed
anakin was dead when he leaves him on
the lobby right he's like i've done my
job i don't need to go up this is my
brother this is the man i've been
training i don't need to stab him in the
head i've done my job i've cut off his
arms and legs
he's burning there's no way the genitals
are definitely gone right uh so i've
done my party walk so he assumes he dies
this was like you know he cracks the
helmet he gets the to the kinder egg
inside of of darth vader and anakin or
darth is like i killed anakin he's like
oh
you did it then my friend is dead he
literally says there's no redemption for
you i'm gonna go yeah i'm gonna go like
i'm gonna go the kid's not here anymore
it's only darth vader i'm gonna call you
darcy i'm a tag and then vader goes on
to kill
tens of thousands of more people i won't
even blame
i won't blame any death star yeah i
won't blame alderaan yeah that's gonna
happen between tarkin and the emperor
that will always happen if you kill
vader that still happens but vader kills
at least ten thousand people police and
the least and that's the next show we'll
see what the next show is
and it's not even like he thought he was
maybe thought he would die on that
planet but you've you've been through
this before kill him yeah you've seen
this finished i don't know why he didn't
think like well i mean i know why he
didn't think like that because they made
the a long time ago but like i'm like i
need some justification here why aren't
you coming i would like for him to go to
try and do it and then just like a
hollow george lucas gets in the way and
he's like you can't no i upset the rules
of this universe the special edition vhs
need to exist i need to remake jar jar i
didn't imagine it like this so
unfortunately you can't do that uh i
think uh
there was something i had to say oh i
think he only wanted to kill anakin once
once once it was confirmed that anakin
was dead he's like that it's not my job
to kill darth my mission is to kill
anakin i'm not here to kill doug that's
all the families he murdered i mean i
agree i agree with you but i'm saying i
think in obi-wan's mind he's like the
thing i the the thing i had to put to
bed was killing anakin skywalker because
he i created him i got to destroy him
but i already did that but i left him on
fire i killed hannie exactly but then
once anakin was or darth vader was like
i killed i killed him he's like great
yeah you know what he's like i know what
i'm gonna say to your son nine years
from now thank you so much
lied to the emperor's face and was
straight up just like no i'm not worried
about him i'm chilling
i love how sassy he is when like you see
the strut and even the way he like
lightsabers like flourish and then as
soon as emperor's like
like there's a different sassy regality
subservience yes oh you're still
thinking about obi-wan he's like no
nothing no
i didn't even talk about him anymore my
helmet was fixed
you have nothing to worry about obi-wan
i mean the emperor
i'm sorry i'm i've got to stop doing
that
were you all happy with our hello there
that way i mean it felt like a worthy
earned moment yeah i screamed so yeah i
was very content
i mean that was very sweet when no one's
like do you want to meet him
well it was kind of like our like we had
that one hello in the third or whatever
episode with with
alien man uh and then like i feel like
that was the avengers assemble of this
right where like cap says avengers and
they cut it right we got the full i was
waiting for when you know vader makes
the hole in the ground which was really
cool throws all the rocks on top of but
the shot is like down below and vader's
up there i was hoping vader would be
like now i have the high ground
i thought for sure he was gonna say i
was like they're gonna do it they're
gonna do it oh that'd be great
they've allowed memes to control our
sequels too much yeah but also the fan
service up here yeah they should have
used it they should have said it they
said hello there which i mean yeah it's
not a meme but we were all like yeah
people have tattooed on their body like
come on yeah yeah yeah because i mean
that's what that's what did anakin right
was i i we're in the third in revenge
that says when obi-wan is like don't do
it i have the high ground he knew anakin
was going to try when he said that yeah
he was baiting him and it worked and i
want to bait him well in their first
fight after the fire is set like when he
goes to running scampers he looks and
then he goes to the high ground like
like obi-wan immediately high grounds
himself so i would love to find that
like twisted on it but yeah too much
fancy it was a lot of fun i think we
were also pretty right about riva going
light side baby still alive
we talked about this offline and i don't
know i can okay so this is my thing this
is my thing the robot processing noises
wow
so i
here
you guys got it for free that wasn't a
good argument i'll give you a real real
good one at the end of the day but
as someone that's like i i like star
wars i love star wars i don't know as
much as these two absolutely do so
that's why i'm gonna point this towards
you guys
so
i don't think she can okay and correct
me chat so if she's going to the light
side i don't think she's ultimately
going to the lights i think she's given
up completely and that doesn't mean
you're going to the light side that just
means you're like i'm done because i
think we're going to see her way in the
future working on a farm and she's going
to be like don't talk to me about jedi's
like she's gonna be like i don't want to
talk about i don't want to do it she's
not like uh
a sakuratana where she's like i'm gonna
start like i still do it on my own time
she's like no i'm done doing it it's
going away with me like i'm gonna stay
here and farm and find myself i think
that's better honestly because i think a
lot of the disney problem has been
villains being too sympathetic like i
think it's really important to have your
villain be approachable and
understandable but there is also a line
where it's like but i don't want to root
for them as like daredevil i think to
the best balance kingpin and matt
murdock both wanted to protect their
city but kingpin was always still bad
yeah so even when you're rooting for
them you felt dirty i think some of the
disney plus shows sometimes they make
the villains so likable in trying to
give them equal screen time that you're
like wait is this still a villain and
i'm glad they didn't do that with reeva
cause i was really afraid episode like
three they turned yeah i'm glad they
didn't go that way i'm glad she didn't
kill luke even though you know i kind of
wanted it but
i'm glad she didn't but also girl she
sweat out her weave and i was like i was
like oh you got stabbed you're running
and that hair is all over the place i
was like i feel you but i was like i
just don't want her to still not be
angry like you're still gonna be angry
they killed all your friends they killed
your loved ones you're looking at luke
you're seeing yourself in him it's like
still be mad at the jedi because obi-wan
didn't help you he could have helped you
so i'm like don't i don't want her to be
like i'm back on the good side now it's
like no they still betrayed you
and he just did it again
again
i'm bringing him here for you i'm going
to help you
yeah oh my god straight up was like we
can work as a team and it's like where
is he well i let him go
the same way yeah i did appreciate
they're on the ship
with ice cubes kid they're getting away
from the the star destroyer they can't
jump to hyperspace but actually at that
same time
uh rifa's made it to tatooine so she
must have found another ship on jabim
got on it hyper jumped over and attacked
that's what i assumed i assumed she just
like gotten our own little ship and just
like people stop leaving not dead people
on the ground because they get away
every time that's right big star wars
problems stop leaving the knot on the
ground you got to finish the job just
don't just stab you got to stab and
swish a little bit
you shouldn't do it vader and the
vader's like i'm gonna do it here okay
i'm gonna do it he just looked at him
he's like yes let's turn this [ __ ] up
to it
i was watching the great inquisitor and
i was like oh my god his acting is so
fun and so good yeah it's so i could not
i couldn't do it i couldn't look at
myself in the mirror and do those lines
like he was having so much fun it was a
highlight for sure old school star wars
was kind of hand-off and then phase two
marvel did that as well and i feel like
this phase five or whatever star wars is
one hole yes like it's like everyone
just
everyone gets one
good stamp and you're good to go that's
it you're good carry on go on here we're
gonna address a couple quick questions
and then we'll get to the rest of them
that you guys are sending into at the
end of the show thank you so much uh we
did run a poll who is ob1 we're likely
to run into again before
before a new hope leia or vader 64
said leia yeah i think if there's
another spin-off from this don't have
the both of them in it ever again let
them stay apart it was special we don't
want to dilute it yeah like i think
uh simon mccann asking why did the hyper
drive work on the shuttle but not for
the ship i think that makes sense you
just can't put everyone on the shuttle
right right i thought there was like a
separate hybrid that happened
was on that ship and then fixed salt
agreed
um
uh and yeah there is kind of like
lingering questions about
really sorry really quick so when matt
in the chat said back in my day star
wars character's just lost
everyone lost a hand and then if you
look at phase two feige's like what if
everybody loses their hands one period
we have this quota that we reach and we
already reached it so no more
um but yeah we're all wondering like is
there going to be more to this you know
deborah chow ewan mcgregor and hayden
christensen it all said they'd hope uh
that uh they they would like to do a
season two they hope there will be a
season two this is a classic thing on
the breaker if you know the thirsty
thespians they want to keep working who
wouldn't want another season of their
show
i feel like they have to look back at it
and this is my this might just be me but
i hope they will look back at it and be
like okay this is what like some of the
fans complaints were how do we address
this because i'm also like i think they
would get more viewers or not more
viewers but more like loud people
interested if they did do darth maul
right and so i'm like maybe your second
season will do a lot cooler
but darth maul i think burning off the
the vader ob1 at the top maybe that's
great yeah like we can go deeper now i
feel like van lorian did a really good
job looking at some of the things from
season one to season two and if they do
that with obi-wan and do an obi-wan show
with maul and do a vader show with like
another team and keep it darker and then
you can have vader i mean i think this
is the scariest vader's been since
empire
generally he stayed terrifying that's so
happy killed those two people just
dragged them out of their house and just
the presence of voice like the whole
thing just felt more ominous than i
think the show worked for so if you give
me a vader show you keep him at that 11
and then let obi-wan fight spider-like
but it's true
that is true he did come off scarier to
me this season yeah yeah it made me
realize what brandon always mentions
that like you can go see him at
disneyland
and he's dancing the memes do not do him
justice i think i'm talking about just
like it about but bring back sam
whitworth how one darth maul samuel
kylo ren was there when i was there on
sunday and i'm sure
i'm not kylo ren from disneyland if
you're watching this i think you were a
child in the suit i was like i'm not
afraid of you and
i was like it was so insane it just
didn't feel like yeah no it wasn't at
all and i was also like i don't want to
take a picture with you i don't know
what you did that's why i know what you
did
that is disney's policy is to have an
eight-year-old
you know i love i love lightyear but man
the dude they got for the dude is just a
dude oh yeah i love that my you're just
a guy it's like hey i'm tom like it's
just the best i'm tom white here
if they do another season
what are they any new characters you'd
like to see i mean riva would be cool to
see where she goes from here do we want
to see the many adventures of high jaws
he scams his way
no absolutely not uh
uh the mole guy that grabs mold guy i
love that zach grass has a seth rogen
impression he sounded just like rogan
yes hey i got you a couple of weirdos
that's so funny
my season's when i killed this little
girl i got her for you so we got to get
from this obi-wan to like sir alec
guinness right so i would have like a
darth maul resurgence and have him be
navigating like okay he's got his horse
back and he's at full strength but he's
also got to eventually land again as a
guy who's rejected the ways so i think
you kind of need like a reverse arc like
he needs to go into like okay i've let
this down like he needs to get on that
spice but he's also got to like he's got
to let go of the ways again right
because
we need him
is gonna be like my guy yeah come on we
gotta we gotta jedi it up
he was the jedi who was like i like
doing all this crazy stuff i'm gonna go
on dates well yeah i'm gonna have a good
time yeah so that means
he was a great jedi called the rule of
two and bring back quagga on the whole
season and we just rock out with him
until they they
it was the last five minutes he had
maybe two sentences i believed him when
he was like i don't want to do tv
because it's liam neeson yeah
and then i'm like if they don't get a
second season i don't get to see him
again yes and that's what i am mad about
right like i'm just like how am i got a
special set of skills and it's training
over the the qui-gon show and it's just
quite good i'm watching it's just a
ghost
look
all i gotta say is more gray jedis on tv
less gray jedis
on my crotch
oh god that's why we want to thank
manscape there's a certain confidence
that comes with being properly groomed
there's an aura a vibe you can just tell
by the way someone carries why am i
looking this camera is the one that's on
look like a crazy person i'm just trying
to read off the prompter just give me
three for one second we call this big
groomed energy and there's only one way
to get that bge
manscaped and we'd like to introduce you
to the best and biggest ultimate hygiene
bundle yet the platinum package 4.0
manscaped is the leader and below the
waist grooming now just trust them with
the rest join the four million men
worldwide who trust manscape by going to
manscape.com for 20 off plus free
shipping with the code break room it's
no secret that was a difficult birth
we've talked to everyone about this
i was born completely covered in hair
the doctor pulled a reverse kool-aid man
and shouted oh no
the nurse dove out the window luckily it
was only the first floor
does a reverse kool-aid man build a wall
yes oh no
try to take her life only the first
floor minimal cuts and bruises manscapes
brand new platinum package 4.0 is the
biggest bundle they've ever offered
giving you bulk discounts on manscape's
top products such as the manscape
platinum package 4.0 it is the one-stop
shop for all the men who deserve it all
they designed this package to allow you
to fully align your hygiene your entire
hygiene routine with their elite
products inside your platinum package
you're going to find this the lawnmower
4.0 trimmer love it weed whacker ear and
nose hair trimmer got to have it like i
said there's something going on inside
my ears right now it might be medical
maybe manscape can help ultra premier
body wash ultra premium two in one
shampoo and conditioner ladies ultra
premium deodorant crop preserver
anti-chafing ball deodorant my personal
favorite the crop reviver ball spray
toner we're losing him we're losing the
balls spray it
they're back
we got a pulse we got a ball pulse
inside my balls
ma'am your balls are alive we saved them
anti-chafing boxers and the shed travel
bag to hold this whole shebang together
now get yourself 20 off and free
shipping with the code break room at
manscape.com you don't use that code you
don't deserve the free shipping we don't
want you to have it okay that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com use
the code break room for the love
of gosh unlock your big groomed energy
with manske and remember when you trim
the hedges the sequoia stands taller
stop changing
get me on camera to you really quick
landscape if you're listening make a
tool that looks like a lightsaber it
would be so fun if you start making them
into weird things like that i'm sure
everyone will violate that's a fun
buzzing sound too
everyone already does i'm just saying
i'll buy like seven in different colors
you should have shaved me when you had
the chance
you are the one who made me uh camera
four if you can flashlight if you're
listening
like like
yeah we also want to let you know that
new rockstars is going to be appearing
live in austin texas keeping it weird as
part of the rtx austin 2022 podcast
festival happening july 1st through july
3rd uh we're going to be doing an
awesome live show a little bit of what
you see here but a lot more trivia and a
lot more fun and audience interaction
tommy will be there jessica will be
there philip's gonna be there eric's
gonna be there it's gonna be a great
time if you're planning on going you
could save on your ticket click the link
in our description and use promo code
new rockstars that's new rockstars all
one word uh you get a little discount on
your ticket um let them know that we
sent you there and there's tons of other
cool podcasts that are going to be at
this festival yeah iffy nowadays fiona
nova elise williams all of rooster teeth
yeah uh they're gonna play among us
they're doing signings i'm not doing a
signing don't ask me to sign anything
but if they pay you good money i'll sign
anything at the rooster
i don't care whatever bring it and i'll
sign it no matter what it is yeah boom
back here that's what
escaped i immediately was going for like
a watermelon yeah
i will shave i'll shave your back and
then i'll sign it okay
if you use the code break room
you got to pay to play baby speaking of
pay to play
it's time for mandatory [ __ ]
yes this this segment that has swept the
nation oh no we have people have been
calling in begging us just do a whole
show of mandatory fun oh don't even have
other hosts just have tommy sit here and
do mandatory fun by himself and i say no
because this is the segment when i bring
my four my three
four including daschle my three best
friends together for a little bit of
non-optional joy with me okay now
guys this is pretty crazy earlier today
i received a transmission oh yeah from
far far away let's go ahead and check
that out now oh okay hello there this
message is for the cast and crew of the
break room this is ben kenobi but not
the old one the young one that everyone
adores nobody just finished with a
spectacular season finale
but no one seems to appreciate this
recent wave of star wars content don't
get it twisted star wars celebration was
absolutely fantastic but why is no one
excited about andor they loved rogue one
in episode five we had vader force slam
a starship and rip it apart like a lego
set
we gave them baby leia what more could
they want they need to understand
and i don't know who better to turn to
than you
help me break room crew
you're my only hope
okay uh
yeah i think that was uh pretty clear
that uh old ben kenobi was hey kind of
took it out on the fans a little bit
more than i would have liked there but
you know you know what that's a rough
guy but uh i think that what we need to
do is uh
make ben and the rest of the kenobi gang
feel loved with some star wars trivia so
actually there were a few more
transmissions ben's gonna ask the
questions and then you guys will answer
so go ahead and hit us with that first
question ben
how many crystals are there in an
inquisitor's lightsaber
great question ben as you know said how
many kyber crystals are in an
inquisitor's lightsaber
is this a trick
no it's yeah
i'm gonna make these guys also you
wouldn't let me know the trivia
questions yes i wouldn't let you know
the trivia questions because the point
of trivia is to not know that okay
yeah you were that's exactly what you
would die
okay i'm ready okay
the answer is two because as you
remember
that's two electric boogaloo she's ready
who was the first sith to pull down a
starship using the force
all right
i forgot i was supposed to be the grand
inquisitor
yes who was the first sith to pull down
a starship using the force now this is
all
star wars materials doesn't have to just
be movies or tv okay okay okay
okay i think i
know and and three
a two
a one okay what were your answers i put
darth plagiate okay i said it's a
similar darth nips darth nibs i went
dooku
i thought i remembered that but the
answer is actually starkiller from the
video game before but you have this
memory too right yes i had a vague
memory of dooku stopping them leaving on
their like escape
cannot wait till we do trivia on arcane
and i'm going to win
i will be the best all right now
third
question how many different lightsabers
have i kenobi had
yes of course he's asked how many
different lightsabers says kenobi used
oh that's fun
in like his entire lifetime like you
didn't bother oh yes in his life
has he used this lightsaber
and i'll take your answers in 39.
three two one i said three i said two i
said four the answer is three
give me my money yes he used uh he is
one as a padawan he used qui-gons and he
used anakin's so
uh
so it's all tied up going into our final
question oh okay give me my spice give
me my spice
how many episodes did it take for me to
actually use my lightsaber in this
series
sorry danson i mean obi-wan ah yes uh
how many episodes of the series did it
take for kenobi to actually use his
lightsaber oh
oh
yes how many episodes were total oh
deep into your mind
look into your hearts the answer could
only come from inside the question one
more time how many episodes of the
series kenobi did it take for kenobi to
finally use this lightsaber this is not
his uh fleshlight lightsaber no we use
that in episode one in that awkward
encounter with a job use that in obi-wan
after dark
yes all right wait wait wait wait wait
just write a number three two one i put
three the average answer is three it's a
three-way
we did not ask nearly enough questions
looked abysmal failure
right we could only con oh listen we
only had obi-wan for a limited amount of
time this is a serious act uh an actor
we have here play his outro for us
well you've done it break room crew
peace has been restored to the galaxy i
cannot thank you enough
may the force be with you
and also with you my god i'm with you
so i guess the real winner today is me
because i didn't have to do it so uh my
price is i'm going to i have a big bowl
of obi-wan kenobi frosted flakes waiting
for me in my office that i'm gonna eat
and i will have the knowledge that when
it comes to kenobi
i am the og i
replaced i got two right yeah i was
shocked i'd get one yeah i was real
worried about americans i got right two
people you guys all tried for first
there was three you're all my special
special friends
all right
that was that was sweet that was a good
mandatory fine thanks
and thank you to our producer dodson who
has an incredible obi-wan kenobi cosplay
and a pretty dang good obi-wan kenobi
that's unrelated to that right yeah no
just a random compliment to a person who
works very hard on that sure that's
sweet of you
so yeah we want to talk more about
kenobi as we wrap up the episode today
answer any questions you guys have any
theories keep sending them out we've got
some great super chats over the show
we're very don't be dumb if you get to
the 200 mark we're gonna do impressions
with swear words we're gonna do some
star wars swearing for you which we know
you like uh td jones sending you a great
super chat just saying hello there hello
yeah what a moment what a moment chrissy
sent in a super chat what is a personal
nickname you have for something in the
star wars universe like i call
lightsabers danger glow sticks also it
was my birthday yesterday happy birthday
chrissy happy birthday
star wars nick or like a cutesy little
thing you'd call something in star wars
i say star skirmish whenever it's quaint
like whenever it doesn't feel like the
scope they wanted for him yeah it's a
star skirmish
i called you know for a while before uh
when we just had darth maul footage and
when the trailers were first coming out
we didn't know his name was darth maul i
called him the devil guy oh the devil he
looked like a devil to me a lot of times
growing up when my parents would ask me
to do something i'd be like but i was
gonna go to tashi station to pick up
some power converters yes
that's your kittens that's your king
what a whiny little baby that's your
king just me said that would be cool if
obi runs into mace yeah like yeah spray
the wrapper
we'll get into it one more perspective
i'm saying it if i see one more person
in the chat say that he's related to
riva i'm going to jump through that guys
again we have to remind you that not all
of the black star wars characters need
to be related i can't like we all want
to stress that
uh but i do please do stick uh stick
around and watch my in-depth
investigation the case with mace
i really want to see we're talking about
reeva carter back in the next season the
mandalorian we go to maf gideon sitting
in jail and someone's like a rebel comes
and knocks like get in your bail's been
paid and uh it's his wife and his wife
is rebel
now we do agree that all of the black
characters aren't married yeah
how do you think the events in the
finale will impact episode four also koi
has been accepted by the live
charters charters he's now one of them
hey this is a giant giant nerd community
and i know that is some of the most
contentious land to try to be a part of
so i appreciate it
they hate
all you want but i know what he eats in
movie theaters that's true she knows the
truth she knows the truth i'm not
bringing it with me there what is that
artichokes artists
i bring artichokes
when i'm trying to lean out i bring in a
nice steamed artichoke don't get
involved okay when you're trying to lean
out that makes sense it's not like not
all the time yeah okay because i also
was an advocate for putting candy and
popcorn yes that's great
when i try to lean out which is never
i just put less candy on the bottom
we were talking about this question over
the office like you can't have like
obi-wan and vader meet again because all
i can think about is their bet you know
their their battle in episode four when
he's like the last time we met i was but
the student but now i am the master or
something like that and it's like
they can't change that line to where
it's like the last time we met you were
the master and i have a student then we
met again
and you were the student and then we met
again and that time you had the
opportunity enough with darth maul in um
the uh in the animated series that i
think they can do it again they can do
it again darth maul kept being like look
at you a mess and i was like dragon ball
you're half robot
i think that's why i love them so much
i'm like go off go go even though you
have no right to i can't wait for more
mall i think this show also showed me
that like it explains a lot of leia like
reaching out to obi-wan and i think they
should meet again i really i liked a lot
of what young leia did in this show but
i would have loved it more if it was
like a teenage leia with a little more
agency and a little more i don't know
why it's cracking nature every time she
hugged him i started to cry i know the
hands every every time
he was like i did know your parents yeah
that was an [ __ ] yeah but you learned
some cool stuff your perseverance and
being angry and my outrage graceful and
wonderful and your dad was
freaking praying i left your dad for
dead i'm not sure
the whole ride in the camel is like what
can i say about her dad like what's a
nice day
dedicated to rage uh determined
tense a lot of fire fire yeah just me
had a couple of super chats obi-wan has
too much heart to finish it i agree like
you know he's trying to be a good jedi
killer i guess i don't kill a lot of
storm troopers it seems like yeah yeah
he doesn't have any hear about those
these are conscripted or maybe these are
the volunteers early on they want either
way so like it's not a good look
alexander dumas is in the chat he's back
from the dead
uh i think it was both okay he also did
the count of monte cristo uh just me
also asking do you guys think obi-wan is
going to have a second season yeah
that's what we're talking about you know
i'm okay with it but yeah get them off
tattooing please please no more shows on
tattooing please i know you've built the
sets
i know the volume is great for doing
desert landscapes but please you know
what i'm doing more tattoos
you know what i haven't seen the the the
real sand part so chad and i don't want
to see anything i love the first i'm
sorry do you think owen killed that guy
who came to be like oh and i told a lady
about you yeah well that guy walked up
he's just buried in the sand that's all
there's so much sand he's got a lot of
bodies
like no loose ends
put him in the wall peru yeah cut
another hole in the middle i don't need
more skywalkers and more sand that's
what star wars needs absolutely
everyone's related and there's just
tattoos also are we excited to see
riva's uh
like lightsaber 100 years in the sand
because she just dropped it and i was
like oh yeah it's going to just be the
fans of tattooing are just the crush
crystals of all the yeah
like a garbage dump in new jersey with
all the mafia guns there's just tons of
echo park's lake
i mean we've been in the last episode
right we saw like a box full of light
sabers just sitting around like if
you're if you're running from the empire
right and you're you're on this like
weird planet jabim you've been waiting
for months to get out of there i pocket
one of those yeah
this one's for me yeah i'm keeping that
i'm keeping it just in case yankee one
it's probably bad you need to go get a
good one thank you a good colt 45.
i mean like like luke just eated his
lightsaber the second ray handed it back
to me he was like
uh i think this is my hope
first five minutes of andor
uh
they're like they're like cassian we've
got a very dangerous smuggling mission
for you you're headed to tatooine
and then he goes not this again even
though he's never been he's never been
he's like we need you to do six months
on tattooing and he's like that john
watts movie just the kids running
through tactics like man we got these
kids these amazing kids they're on
hanging out
i just really like latin bean dip's name
and also latin bean dips question who's
the best fighter though
out of everyone out of every i still
hold down for it's a tie between mace
windu and darth maul okay uh the fact
that he killed liam neeson is enough for
me to be like i know he lost to kenobi
but like you killed her oh you killed
somebody it took both of them yeah like
he got weakened so brought in the double
blade yeah i'm gonna go mull for me and
the fact that he comes back so sassy i
got that only again vegeta energy i
respect you i mean i will say obi-wan
really turned it on in this episode
which i liked i liked the move of
smashing the the breathing box with the
hills yeah that was like the fun so just
throwing rocks behind him just like
standing there
so dope you know make a little force
field to protect himself from the rocks
which again vader
you know he's still alive and you start
walking around i know
i think vader likes to do the walk away
and then what just kidding i was ready
for it
he likes to pull yeah he's very
theatrical
you're right have you ever worn a cape
that's all you want right he's very
theatrical much like the count of monte
cristo a lot of kids totally we're back
to dumas we're back to dumas chat guys
this is dumbasses on dumas
dafoe playing damascus with a
chart-topping hit from macy
wrap it all up yeah baby running up that
hill i did like to call back to their
little back-to-back
move that they did in the flashback yeah
they did it again in the fight i was
like that's a cute little move yeah i
like the fight i could have used more
too but i liked the fight a lot i was
impressed i don't cut away from it i
like yeah maybe that's what really hit
me in the back of the head uh that's
what the real donkey punch was i feel
like i really wanted it saber hilt to
the back of the hand you got it you
walked him you walked brandon brandon
headed out
brandon said no i liked reba
i love that he broke her lightsaber was
just like no take it come on let's go
like i let's go girl let's go come on i
do like that you can snap it and it's
like still working there yeah the kyber
crystals just hang out exactly on the
side someone said what color lightsaber
would you guys want to have and i think
we've been asked this before and maybe
we have purple's great
you know i do like the yellow i mean but
you gotta go i like classic green the
green's my favorite whenever i see it i
feel like it's it's so when you've had
the green you're like ooh the green i
would go flamingo pink oh
that's a very that's a very pink yeah
flamingo like not not like blush i'm
talking flamingo if people would see you
from so far away people be like oh
there's times oh i know those subtle
green lightsabers that are
blend into the terrain
hey you know what there are jungle
planets i didn't see them yeah yeah so
they're better than your people when
they're bopping around indoors it's real
subtle compared to pink flamingo i would
have and i'd wear like a dark blue jedi
robes with pink stripes and everyone
would be like there goes the pink band
i'd be like that guy that's the guy that
you buy spice from yeah that guy sells
some real spicy that's the pink stink
you guys want to get nuts let's get nuts
oh we got six dollars to get the start
to get the star wars swears guys come on
so close we're so close and we're
running out of time
who's been feeding the kenobi's camel
thing yeah
when i saw that camel thing at the end
again i was like oh it's still alive
i think you can go like a regular camel
storing the meat it needs to eat once a
year
is that how camels work i thought it was
one it's a desert-based animal it knows
how to go along
i also deposit that it ate the java the
jawwa came back to check out
and he was like
and then the camera was like wow
[Music]
apologies if i butchered that name i
said little leia was the best she was
adorable so
i'll admit like when they showed her in
the first episode i did not expect to
see her i don't know why it makes so
much sense why you would see her and
that she would be the focus that makes
so much sense when you think about it
didn't expect it and when i realized it
was happening i was like i like joking
and
crying like the baby away yeah
they're so good
baby luke i don't care about it all the
babies
roast his ass roast him roast oh thank
you oh in the tom a couple of super
chats enjoy from
what a great way to guys just me love
you guys uh and john costa uh uh
director john sending in a little from
uh john oh my god
this is you're taking your money and
putting it back into your money
john saying let's [ __ ] do it oh my
god so many
absolutely
king beautiful you are the king all
right let's do some star wars swears all
right for these uh uh people does anyone
have one i got one
some [ __ ] how the emperor
yes
wonderful
it really didn't it was right there
then i'm in and i buy the whole story
um i'll do my r2d2 scream but maybe with
like a little little spice yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i've got a bad [ __ ] feeling about
this
uh uh
this is this is 3po and he's like oh oh
dear i've crushed them they're all
[ __ ] dead
smashed into little human shits now i
guess it's just us uh to me
a little piece of [ __ ] garbage don't
beep at me you little [ __ ] i can't
believe i had those dumb flesh bags get
crushed oh well
got to go
oh anthony daniel's reading script
that's the subtext that's like this is
happening
and that's our show today thank you so
much for tuning in today thank you for
all our super chats that begin to get us
over um
you know that's it for kenobi you know
maybe we'll have more to talk about as
the days go on tomorrow we're going to
talk ms marvel uh episode three so be
sure to catch up on that if you haven't
yet uh uh jessica really wants to try
about umbrella and cats yeah send in
some questions catch up on that send
some super chats for jessica's sake
please yes she watched all of them i
watched
umbrella academy right after kenobi i
was like you know what i want to try one
episode of umbrella academy stayed up
till 10 a.m basically watching that dang
show how'd you like it it's great it's
really good
you might need to re-watch the last
episode of season two because you will
be a little confused in a minute but it
is so fun
to season two i was confused yeah like i
gotta rewatch this again
but thank you for joining us
okay thank you for joining us have a
great rest of your wednesday we'll see
you tomorrow right here on the break
room hit that like button let us get it
see you later roomies breakers